RETO MEIER: Hello, my
name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: We'll be looking
at home screen widgets, and
interviewing Kevin Barry, of
TeslaCoil Software, to learn
some tips and tricks for
improving in the efficiency--
Hello, my name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: We'll be looking
at home screen widgets, and
interviewing--
Hello, my name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: We'll be looking
at home screen widgets, and
interviewing Kevin Barry, of
TeslaCoil Software, to learn
some tips and tricks for
improving in the efficiency of
your widgets.
All in the next 30 minutes on
this week's App Clinic.
Home screen widgets are an
interesting category, as they
can be either released by
themselves, or value adds to
existing apps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And by providing
a window into your app
directly on the home screen,
widgets can be a powerful tool
for increasing user engagement,
and encouraging
people to get back
to your app.
RETO MEIER: Now to get started,
you really need to
think about how you're going
to present your widget.
So perhaps more than any other
app type, widgets really need
a lot of attention to detail
on the design side, even
before you start developing.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right,
because they're always there,
and they're very, very small.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So start by
checking out the widget design
patterns on the design tab
at developer.android.com.
RETO MEIER: And then, it's time
to head over to the app
widgets API guide, where you
can learn all the practical
details of exactly how you put
your design in action.
So we're not going to the
specific details of how to
build an app, as all that
information is already
available online.
But what we do want to do is
have a look at some tips for
making your widgets a little
bit more awesome.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
Users love widgets as a way to
keep information front and
center, and as a way to
customize your home screen so
that it's designed
uniquely for you.
RETO MEIER: Now with limited
space available on the home
screen, it's important
to do a good job
to keep your widgets--
and help them stay
front and center.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right, you don't
want people getting annoyed
with your widgets and
uninstalling them.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So it comes down to doing
things like this-- not
draining the battery, making
sure that they have timely,
up-to-date information, that
they have a UI that's
consistent with the platform but
is still representative of
what you're trying to do.
And then they should be as
interactive as they can be.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
absolutely.
It's really annoying to have a
widget that's just sitting
there, being a larger version
of a shortcut.
You want to be able to not only
put information on the
screen, but also make
it accessible.
So for instance, the calendar
widget does a
great job of that.
RETO MEIER: And so over the
years, the power of widgets
has increased as the platform
has developed to give greater
support for how they can be
integrated within it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now this started
with support for collection
widgets, including lists
and galleries.
Then we had the ability to
re-size widgets, which I'm
telling you, that's a god-send
for my calendar.
RETO MEIER: More recently, we
also provided support to embed
widgets directly into the lock
screen, and this has opened up
a whole new world of
possibilities.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
This is extremely powerful.
It allows users to perform
actions or view data without
even having to unlock
their phone.
RETO MEIER: And as is typically
the case, along with
this great power comes
similarly great
responsibility.
So it's really important to take
a few precautions when
allowing your widget to be
lock screen-enabled.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The first thing
you want to think about is
being careful about exposing
information.
The thing is, your lock screen
is what you see when the
phone's not locked-- or when
a phone is locked.
So anyone can pick up the
phone and see that
information.
If you're exposing things on
that lock screen that have to
do with your meetings you're
having at work that have
confidential topics, people
that are phoning you,
whatever-- you have to
remember all of that
information is going
out into the world.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
In many cases, that's a decision
for the users to
make, particularly
with something
like calendar or email.
It's up to you how sensitive
you think that is.
But you need to make sure as a
development that it's really
obvious to your users what data
or actions that they're
effectively removing that lock
screen protection from.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And for
most user data,
that's fairly obvious.
But especially for actions--
it's important to protect any
actions that might cost the user
money or risk exposing
private information.
You want to make sure that's in
an activity that's launched
from the widget, not
directly available
on the widget itself.
And even though it should be
obvious to the user what
they're exposing when they add
a calendar or text message or
recent calls widget to their
home screen, you might want to
give them a little
reminder anyway.
Because a lot of times, you
think, oh yeah, I'm going to
put my calendar there.
And you don't dig deep and
think, wow, sometimes my
calendar has some pretty
sketchy stuff on it.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So today we're going to look at
three home screen widgets,
starting with the Minimalist
Shortcut
and Terra Clock widgets.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And then we'll
break out the scalpels for a
particularly penetrating look
at DashClock, from our very
own Roman Nurik, who turns out
isn't a very good designer at
all, and his app is garbage.
I'm just kidding.
Let's take a look at Minimalist
Shortcut.
RETO MEIER: OK, so I love that
this widget maintains its
philosophy within its
logo and banner.
So it's all about minimalism,
and they've taken that
approach here.
I'd probably go a step further,
though, and consider
removing the "Declutter Your
Home Screen" text, and really
tighten up that banner
a little bit more.
I don't think it really adds
a lot of information, and
actually just makes it a little
bit less minimalist.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Ah, you know,
I actually have
the opposite feel.
I think it's kind of
cool, actually.
RETO MEIER: OK, well,
there you go.
Now this is a screen
shot provided in
the Google Play listing.
And it's worth noting that it's
not immediately obvious
where the widget actually is.
But that's as much a feature
as it is a bug in this
particular instance.
The point of this app is to
try and have these very
minimalistic widgets.
Now one of the confusing things
is that each of the
screenshots has a different
wallpaper, and a slightly
different layout.
So it's difficult to tell what's
a widget, and what's a
background, and when things
are changing and how.
So in any case, you can see what
they're trying to achieve
here with each of those
tiny little androids--
a really light gray on the dark
gray background along the
edge of the screen.
Now I wanted to stop by calling
out a common challenge
for widget developers.
And if you're building an app
that happens to have a widget,
then there's a variety of things
you can do to help
encourage your users to
check out the widget.
And even if they never
find it, they can
still use the app.
But what if, as in this case,
it's just a widget?
Well, a lot of developers will
still choose to include a
launcher activity to
help users find and
activate that widget.
And there's nothing
wrong with that.
That's perfectly appropriate.
It stops people from hitting
install, and then going, oh, I
installed your app and
I can't find it.
But as this is going to be the
user's first interaction with
your app, it's really important
to make sure that
the aesthetic of your app
is maintained in this
introductory activity.
So in the case of Minimalist
widget, that means paying a
little more attention to the
padding, and maybe even
considering switching to
something like a light style
with a white background.
Something which matches the
banner, the logo, this idea of
minimalism.
It's also worth noting that the
specific instructions like
the ones given here, they're
going to change depending on
the OS version.
And in fact, on my Jelly Bean
device, this doesn't work.
Long-pressing on the home screen
doesn't bring up the
widget chooser.
So it's something you want to
think about when providing
specific instructions that you
may want to check to see what
version of the OS it is.
And even still, a lot of users
are going to have their own
custom launches, their own
custom home screens, which are
going to be different again.
So you really want to consider
perhaps providing links to
external resources, rather than
telling people exactly
what they should do.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And it's worth
mentioning that, when you talk
about the padding, this is one
thing that makes your app look
really unprofessionalism, is
when you've just got a big
block of text, and it goes
all the way across.
Because, obviously, you didn't
really do any layout.
But as I learned while we were
trying to do some sample apps
last week, it's actually really,
really difficult to
make that look attractive.
So we're going to put out a
sample app fairly soon here
about making good, readable text
layouts that work from
Froyo on up.
You can do it with spaces
on Jelly Bean.
But--
Jelly Bean, I think actually,
ICS had it.
RETO MEIER: I think
ICS, as well.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But pre-ICS,
you didn't have it.
RETO MEIER: So the purpose of
Minimalist Shortcut, as I've
kind of implied already, is to
let you have shortcuts to your
favorite apps while keeping
your screen
as simple as possible.
It's basically a way of having
shortcuts without covering up
your awesome wallpaper.
And now, they're currently in
beta, so if this sounds like
something you're into, now
would be a great time to
download the app, provide them
some feedback, help them build
something even more awesome.
Now speaking of which, here's
a little bit of candid
feedback for you guys to help
you create an even better app.
This is the config activity
that's displayed when you add
a new widget.
It's got everything you need.
But the presentation
can be a little
challenging, shall we say?
Now this is something
that comes up a
lot on The App Clinic.
And I know a lot of developers
to find this to be kind of
really nitpicky advice.
So I'm going to explain just
really quickly why this is so
important, why we keep harping
on about this.
Most users are going to judge
both the utility and quality
of the app within the first few
seconds of opening it up.
Now fairly or not, most of that
judgment is instinctual.
And it's based on the UI
aesthetics, and the usability
of that app.
So that first impression
here is of something
really quite complex.
There's this list of options
that's totally comprehensive,
but that also means
it's really long.
So I'm scrolling for a long time
before I see everything
that's there.
Now as a first time user, I'm
not sure which of these
settings is required, which are
optional, and, in fact,
the most important setting-- the
one which lets me choose
the shortcuts and the icons
that I want to use--
isn't obvious to find.
And in fact, it's not even
here on the front page.
Now getting this right
is a challenge.
And in fact, it's probably the
area for a lot of widgets
where you're going to need to
spend the most time in terms
of your design is figuring out
how do you present this
one-off config settings to
people in a way that they can
find intuitive, and
not challenging.
You want to have the things you
need there without hiding
too much of the functionality.
But you don't want to display
everything and intimidate them
till they go away.
So in lot of cases, this is
where good defaults and easy
editing comes in really handy.
You just need to make it really
easy for me to create
that first widget, and
then with some
really sensible defaults.
So in this example, you may
choose some of the most common
pre-packaged apps, build
shortcuts to them directly
with what you think are
the most common icons.
And then make it really easy for
users to click something
within your widget set, too,
to edit that and modify it.
All right.
So that's all I want to
talk about in terms
of Minimalist Shortcuts.
Pretty good app.
I think it's basically some
nitpicky UI changes, which
could make it even
more powerful.
So let's take a look at
TerraTime, by top developer
Sterling Udell Now
I love the icon.
A little less excited
about the banner,
which is a little crowded.
Wouldn't you agree?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, this is one
of those banners where it
feels like there's a lot of
effort put into a certain set
of elements on the banner.
And then the rest of it was like
handed off to an intern
or something.
TerraTime there is in
a really flat font.
It's not probably the
best font for this.
It would be very difficult to
read on a small device.
But the background
bitmap I love.
It's really cool.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
And it gives you a really good
indication of the app.
Now I should point out, having
looked at TerraTime--
and this is not a new app.
You can see that Sterling is
in fact one of our top
developers.
So this is a really popular app
that a lot of people love.
And once we get to see some of
the screenshots, you'll see
just how beautiful it is.
And so making sure that that
first impression is consistent
with the awesome graphics of the
app itself, I think, is a
really simple but important
first step you can take.
Interesting.
Now, unlike Minimalist
Shortcuts, TerraTime is an app
as well as a widget.
So it has the advantage of being
able to show this when
you launch the app.
Now this is a pretty
stunning UI.
You've got the earth semi-lit,
based on the current time.
You've even got the lights in
the night sky showing in the
area that is currently at night,
which is incredible.
But we're not looking
at apps today.
So let's take a look at the
widgets that you can install.
So there are in fact two
of them, and this is
what they look like.
And they're both visually
stunning.
They're really good examples
of the power of a widget to
really customize your home
screen, and make it something
that you really like
to look at.
And I think it's fair to say
that both of these options are
significant improvements over
the default analog clock
widget, I think.
Yeah.
So Sterling's biggest challenge
here is really
around efficiency.
He's got this rich dynamic
content that needs to be
regularly updated.
And when you're building
widgets, it's vital that you
minimize the required update
frequency of them.
And also, minimize the amount of
data that you're regularly
sending to your widget.
So you'll note, for example,
that there's no second hand on
the display.
So at most, he's only going to
need to update that widget
every minute.
And hopefully, he's found
ways to do it even less
frequently than that.
It's also great to see that both
widgets are resizable.
And they're available as lock
screen widgets, as well.
And in fact, after playing with
this today, I've set the
globe widget as my new default
home screen icon--
lock screen icon--
because it just looks
so stunning.
And they've done a really great
job in that it scales
really well between when it's
sort of full lock screen,
between when the keyboard is
available and the globe is
compressed.
So, really thrilled,
really impressive.
And we're going to learn some of
the tricks that you can use
to have something like this,
this rich UI, without draining
the battery, or risking crashing
the launcher when we
talked to Kevin later today.
So what else?
Finally, let's take a look at
DashClock, a new release from
our very own Roman Nurik.
I think you looked at
this in more detail.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yes, yes.
And let's just get it out of the
way right now-- this is a
masterpiece of beautiful,
clean, intuitive design.
It sets the standard by which
all apps should be measured.
And it's the last lock screen
widget you will ever need.
So, let's rip it apart
a little bit.
So first off, the lock screen--
or, I'm sorry, the
feature graphic, I
think, could be a
little bit better done.
The title has more space
that it could take up.
I don't think you should be
afraid of letting your title
overlap other elements
in your scene.
It needs to be really,
really big.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And especially
with its extremely minimalist
feature graphic, it could really
use a little bit more.
In fact, I would take out the
device with the 3D look, and
maybe just zoom in on the widget
itself to help people
understand what it is.
RETO MEIER: But really, you're
just bitter because there's
all those gradients
in the background.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I know.
He never lets me do gradients.
RETO MEIER: I think he has
the gradient license.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, it makes
me feel a little bit better
that he still feels forced to
use that horrid blue that he
makes us use.
OK, so this is a
wonderful app.
This is what you see when
the app is launched.
There's a very obvious
set of extensions.
It's really, really easy to
understand how you're going to
add an extension, because he
went ahead and put an add
extension button as the last
thing in this list.
It's really easy to manage
the extensions.
In fact, the only complaint
I had was that--
probably because I'm old--
I wasn't able to rearrange the
extensions very easily.
Once you get a lot of
extensions in here--
Roman did put in a great
drag-and-dropper re-arranger.
It's very, very fast.
It's very, very fluid.
But only works if you grab the
absolute left-hand side there
where that little bitmap
handle is.
The one that says grab
me obviously.
But the reason I feel like this
is worth talking about is
that you can swipe the
notification--
or, swipe the extension to
dismiss it, just like a
notification.
And you can swipe it
from anywhere.
So the horizontal swiping
works when your finger's
anywhere on the extension.
And vertical swiping only
works in one place.
Now, that kind of confused me.
I thought that was
unnecessary.
You'll notice that some
extensions, but not all, have
extra screens available.
And notice that Roman's put
really nice looking chevrons--
I'm just kidding.
He put his Settings icon on the
one's that have settings,
so it's really obvious how to
get to the second page if
there is one.
And it's also really obvious
which extensions don't have a
second page.
So bravo there.
The second page is also an
interesting study in how to do
an action bar right.
So he's gone to a page of
settings for an extension
which may or may not have been
written by the author of the
app, because DashClock actually
accepts third-party
extensions.
Really kind of cool.
So he's changed the action bar
from blue to black, and then
of course but a nice little icon
in the corner there to
let you know how you can
get back to your
main settings page.
When you actually use this
widget, it can display in two
different modes.
There's sort of compact mode
here, where you see just the
clock, and a minimal version
of some of the widgets or
extensions that you've chosen.
Or, the full mode, where
you can see all of the
information.
The only thing that I thought
was difficult to use about
this app actually was that,
while I can customize a great
deal about the appearance, I
couldn't customize it with a
preview that was on top
of my wallpaper.
So as you can see, it was
difficult for me to get a set
of appearance settings that
actually worked with the kind
of busy wallpaper that
I have on my phone.
So I was a little disappointed
in that.
I was also a little disappointed
in some of the
extensions.
I actually don't know which ones
Roman wrote, and which
ones other people wrote.
But as you can see in this
shot, there's a couple of
extensions.
For instance, the upcoming
alarms, or the mail extension,
that are perfect.
Just a little icon with all of
the information you need.
But then there's a couple of
other extensions that get cut
off, and get ellipsified.
And that seems to me to be
a really big problem.
I don't know if that area is
just too small, or if it needs
some more design thought.
Or maybe Roman just needs to do
something about third-party
extensions.
But as soon as you see ellipses
in that area, you get
really confused.
The only other thing that I was
a little bugged about was
the appearance dialogue, which
I don't have a screenshot of.
And the reason I don't is
because I've got a lot of
nitpicks, but they're
all design nits.
And they don't really
have anything to do
with The App Clinic.
So Roman and I are going
to have a little
meet-up in New York.
And I'm going to show him
exactly what's going on.
Then, if I'm lucky, I'll
be back to show.
RETO MEIER: No guarantees.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right.
So let's go ahead and move on.
RETO MEIER: So some of the
most important aspects of
building good widgets
are pretty much
invisible to the user.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, but they're
not invisible to the
app that's hosting
your widgets.
So luckily, we have the
developer of several app
widget hosting apps, Kevin
Barry, of TeslaCoil.
And he is the developer of the
app launcher Nova Launcher.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, we interviewed
him yesterday to
find out what he's learned
about good widget design.
So to find out a little bit more
about how you can build
really great quality widgets,
we've got Kevin Barry, from
TeslaCoil Software, developer of
a very popular home screen
replacement, Nova Launcher.
Now, he's been developing Nova
Launcher, which is a
replacement for the home screen,
which means he can see
first-hand what happens when
you build a widget which
doesn't really work very well.
So let's throw it over
to Kevin to find out
a little bit more.
So can you start off by telling
us a little bit about
yourself, and TeslaCoil
Software.
KEVIN BARRY: Sure.
So as Reto said, I'm Kevin.
I do Nova Launcher and
WidgetLocker, which both can
host widgets.
TeslaCoil Software is just me,
so it's a small operation.
Nova Launcher is built off the
open source Android launcer so
that gives me a good
place to work with.
RETO MEIER: Excellent,
excellent.
And so it's just yourself.
Are you able to do this
full-time, or is this a hobby
that you do on the weekends?
KEVIN BARRY: Yeah, this has
been my full-time job.
Just WidgetLocker alone
was enough to be my
full-time job, so.
RETO MEIER: That's fantastic.
KEVIN BARRY: It's worked
well for me.
RETO MEIER: Always good to see
if someone who is able to take
something fun, and turn
it into a day job.
So nicely done.
All right, so I guess
what we're talking
about today is widgets.
And so, can you tell us a little
bit about how is it
you're able to give us some
of these efficiency gains.
Or, how do you get that extra
insight into what
makes a good widget?
KEVIN BARRY: Well, so a lot of
the launcher is displaying the
widgets, and being
fast and smooth.
And displaying the widgets
is a lot harder
than you would think.
The widgets are generally
content-rich, which it makes
sense for the widgets
provider.
And it makes sense
to the user.
They want to see the
beautiful images.
But it uses a fair
amount of memory.
And so this--
just using the memory, Nova
Launcher can hit its memory,
or any launcher can hit its
memory limits for having too
many of these widgets.
Or changing out these images can
cause garbage collection,
which is going to slow the
scroll of the launcher.
So really, I like to see the
well designed widgets there
that are just using right image
size or that are using
these images.
They're sending them
efficiently, so there's less
work on the launcher, and it
keeps everything smooth.
RETO MEIER: All right.
So then basically, the better
the widget, the more smooth,
fast, and efficient your
launcher can be.
KEVIN BARRY: Yeah.
Many users care about this.
And they will start noticing
it's not the launcher, it's
the widget.
And they'll ask me for widget
recommendations.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
So that's yet another
vested interest.
It's interesting.
It's something we found last
year at I/O. We made a big
deal about Project Butter,
making everything smoother and
faster, and everything else.
So it becomes incredibly
important when you're
embedding someone else's app--
you know, their widget into
your app if you want what
you're doing to be smooth
and buttery.
And users-- like you say--
really do care.
It's important that the things
you're putting in
there work as well.
So what are some of the most
common best practices, or I
guess maybe anti-patents--
either way you want to look at
it-- that you've seen widget
developers use or not use, which
you'd like to share.
KEVIN BARRY: So the main thing I
wanted to talk about was how
to set the images.
And so, there's two popular ways
of a setting the images.
One is to use the
remote views.
They have a set bitmap or
set image view bitmap.
And this is pretty nasty.
If you use it for a small
bitmap, it's fine.
And it's convenient, because you
just generate your bitmap,
and you send it.
But what has to happen here
is, first, your service--
your widget service has to make
a copy of all the pixels
of the bitmap.
So it's a large amount.
Then it gives it to the Android
framework, where that
has to hold onto it for
a little while.
Then it sends it to
the launcher.
The launcher then has to
unparcel that, so it's
creating another copy of it.
So a large amount-- double the
memory needed for the image.
And then we can ultimately
display it.
So this is-- it's creating
garbage.
And Android has a transaction
size limit, so you
individually can only
transfer so much.
And I only [INAUDIBLE]
can see so much.
And if I have too many widgets
sending updates at
once, I can't it.
I'll crash.
So sending bitmaps through
parcels, through binders--
it's bad.
There's a better method
which just uses the
imaging site image URI.
So this means that your binder
overhead is really small.
You're just making it URI,
then sending that over.
Then the launcher
itself loads it.
There's some tricks to using
this, though, too.
It means you have to have a
URI, so you need a content
provider for it.
And previously, I've seen
widgets use the
file:/sys/ as the URI.
And this worked, but some future
version of Android is
going to have to read external
storage permission.
And the default launcher
doesn't have
that at this time.
I kind of doubt it
will get it.
So you don't want to be using
this file:/// URI.
So you need to create your own
kind of wrapper URI that can
just open up the info stream,
and send it off.
I don't a good example
of that, as I'm
not making the widget.
I'm just receiving it.
Another downside of the second
[INAUDIBLE] is it's not
asynchronous, but neither is
the second entry of bitmap.
This is something that hopefully
a future version of
Android framework can help
with is letting widgets
[INAUDIBLE]
asynchronously, not like
in the launcer.
And you still want to use small
images here, because
even though you're not creating
a copy of it, but
you're still getting this
potentially large image to
launch display.
And so Launcher has
to scale it down.
That's taking time to scale
it, and it's using the
launcher's memory quicker.
I've seen some contact widgets,
scroll the contact widgets.
So they'll look nice.
You can fling through
and they scroll.
But when you fling through--
[INAUDIBLE]
and they're loading the full
size contact picture, which
can be 1,000 pixels wide.
And you're displaying
it at 96x96.
So you could scale those ahead
of time, save them to the SD
card, or save them to your
original storage or something,
and just give the launcher the
smallest version you need.
RETO MEIER: That makes
a lot of sense.
I wonder if along the same
lines, using something like--
I remember exactly the name--
but drawable where you're able
to set the image level, so
that you have basically,
rather than having to send
through the bitmap of the
drawable every time you want to
change it, you could just
basically send through the int
value of the level that you
want to display.
Would that sort of approach
work has similarly?
KEVIN BARRY: Yeah, for
something like--
I imagine [INAUDIBLE]
you could use something
like that.
But for something where you're
getting dynamic contents, it's
not in your resources.
You're not going to be
able to do that.
RETO MEIER: That makes
a lot of sense.
So going on the same lines, you
were mentioning that if
you get too many updates from
too many widgets at the same
time, then that's going to
cause you problems in
processing all of those.
And it's something which we've
talked about before, as well,
which is widgets--
it's important to keep
them updated.
But it's also important not
to refresh them too often.
From your experience, do you
have sort of a best practice
of what you would recommend as
an appropriate frequency with
which to refresh your widgets?
KEVIN BARRY: I guess it really
just happens when it happens.
Like Nova Launcher actually
tries-- if you're scrolling
through the screen, it tries
to kind of defer
those widget updates.
But it's tricky to that.
The framework's really
not built for that.
So it can't always
manage to do so.
Really, the only real problem
I've had is when people have
had animated widgets, which
Android does not support
animated widgets.
RETO MEIER: No, it doesn't.
KEVIN BARRY: And any hack to do
it slows the whole system
to a crawl.
It's really bad.
Don't do animated widgets.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
And it's one of the key tips
that we say is you should
really only be updating
kind of on demand.
And certainly no more frequently
than every sort of
30 minutes.
It's almost like you want to
send as much content to a
widget as you can, and have it
use things like image pages to
modify the content without
having to sort of send stuff
to it to constantly
have to process.
So I wonder, efficiency aside,
are there certain things which
you are seeing a lot of people
making mistakes on.
Things causing crashes in
widgets, which you then have
to deal with within
your launcher?
KEVIN BARRY: So widgets
can crash--
can and do crash the launcher.
So Nova Launcher tries to catch
these, and just crash
the widget, not the
whole thing.
But then I save the crash
report, so I can try to
contact widget developers.
But I can't tell [INAUDIBLE].
So some common things are--
there's a legal state exception
that can happen if
you update a list view
adapter not from
the UI thread without--
and this can happen
to any of us, too.
But it happens widgets, too.
So when you're updating the
adapter used for your
scrollable widget, make sure
you've found the best
practices there.
You're updating it from the
UI thread on your--
you want to find any changes.
There's transaction too large
which I kind of touched about
before, which is, generally,
bitmaps.
But no matter what you're doing,
don't embed a huge
amount of information in
your widget update.
Try to get it from a content
provider if you can.
Oddly enough, there's security
exceptions sometimes.
Sometimes widgets will ask the
launcher to splice them from a
content provider it doesn't
have access to.
Like getting something from a
context provider or whatever.
I imagine these are caught
pretty quickly.
But some like the LG launcher
does have more permissions.
It has permissions to the
context provider.
So if you just test on some
skinned phone, you're not
necessarily going to see this.
So you really want to test
on a third-party
launcher, as well.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
And that's a good point,
as well, right?
In that the widgets themselves
are running within your--
or the launchers process,
which means that the
permissions which your app
needs, or what your widget
needs, it depends on what the
home screen, the launcher
actually has.
KEVIN BARRY: And you can't--
no launcher actually does--
it is a [INAUDIBLE] for an SD
card, because I use it for
other things.
You can't count on a launcher
having that.
The default Android
launcher doesn't.
Well, it does now, because
Android allows anything to it.
But when Android doesn't, the
Android-- the default launcher
probably won't.
And the different launchers
behave different.
This is different from
the widget crashing.
But on the Galaxy S III,
the default launcher--
Samsung's launcher--
doesn't apply any padding
to the widgets.
But Ice Cream Sandwich said
that widgets get--
it's generally 80
dp of padding.
So if you test your widget in
the Samsung launcher, then you
test it in a third-party
launcher, or you test it in
the stock Android launcher,
you're going to see the
padding's different.
And there's not-- you can't
really control this.
You can't detect if you're
running on Samsung, you can
add extra padding, because
they might be using a
third-party launcher.
So just test so it looks good
either with the padding stock
Android has, or without
structure
which it doesn't have.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, that's
a really good point
for testing, as well.
Sorry, I interrupted.
Go on.
KEVIN BARRY: Sure.
One more exception I wanted to
point out was when you're
dealing with a list view, and
you have different view types.
So this is sometimes you have a
header, and then you have an
actually item.
You have to return a count
for get view type count.
And so in a normal app, if you
don't return the correct value
here while you're scrolling
through it,
your app will crash.
In the case of widgets, if you
return the wrong get view type
count, then the launcher itself
is going to crash.
RETO MEIER: Fun times.
KEVIN BARRY: And you'll see in
the right index out of balance
exception, add scrap view--
that's the key there.
So there's fixes to probably
increase your get view type
count to the correct number.
RETO MEIER: Right, and
that's a good tip.
That's actually a good point
you made earlier, as well,
about testing.
I think a lot of people are
going to just use an emulator,
or whichever device they happen
to own, to test their
widgets, not considering the
fact that not only are you
going to have different home
screens from different
manufacturers.
But in fact, users may download
things like Nova
Launcher to have their own
third-party launcher.
So I think it's a good tip for
people building widgets to
test on multiple launcher
implementations to make sure
it doesn't just work
on stock Android.
Great.
Well, that's definitely
really helpful.
I think a lot of really
good tips there for
people building widgets.
It would be remiss of me not
to ask what some of your
favorite widgets are.
KEVIN BARRY: One of widget I
like, but other developers
will probably like to use, as
well, is Appmonger, which it
shows your app sales
for the day, or
whatever you set it to.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
KEVIN BARRY: So that's nice to
have on your home screen, to
keep an eye on how you're
apps are doing.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
KEVIN BARRY: Android Pro
Widgets is another
nice set they have.
Scrollable widgets for like
Twitter and calendar, and
everything--
contacts.
And I've worked with the
developer there to work out
some performance issues.
So they're pretty
good now about
using proper size images.
RETO MEIER: Excellent.
Cool.
Well, all right, thank you
very much for your time.
I very much appreciate you
coming on and sharing some of
your experience and
wisdom on widget
creation with our audience.
So thanks very much,
and I hope to talk
to you again soon.
KEVIN BARRY: Thanks Bye.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So some really
useful tips there from Kevin.
Thank you, Kevin.
That was fascinating.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, thanks
for stopping by.
We appreciate it, and would
invite any of the developers
whose apps we're going
to be a looking at to
get in touch, and--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh,.
Absolutely.
RETO MEIER: --and offer some
of their of feedback.
So our next step is to take a
closer look at today's apps,
and see how close they are
to being pure Android.
So to do that, as always,
we're going to pass them
through each of these
checklists.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Till
then, we can--
you can find our pure Android
collection at
bit.ly/PureAndroid.
And you can nominate your
app for consideration
by adding it to--
RETO MEIER: Our Trello page.
You find that by searching for
"App Clinic Trello." We've
actually updated this recently
to give a little bit more
insight into exactly what
we're planning to
do week over week.
So we're going to be reaching
out to some developers
specifically to ask if we can
review their apps online.
And we would encourage you to
self-nominate by going there,
finding out what's happening
in the coming weeks, and
throwing your app in there.
Would also help us out if you
would give us some contact
details, so we can reach out
and talk to you beforehand.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Now, before we go, I got
to ask you this.
Because we talked about how the
Minimal launcher had an
app icon that's in the launcher,
so you can get to
its Settings page.
Roman's widget does not.
I think it should.
What do you think?
RETO MEIER: I think it's a
really interesting question.
I think if you're building a
widget which is going to
target pretty much every Android
device which can have
widgets, then I think it
probably makes sense to have
some sort of icon there.
The challenge or opportunity
with Roman's is that it's only
available for devices
running Android 4.2.
And now especially, that tends
to be pretty new phone
purchases, more of the sort of
upper end of the techie, geeky
sort of equilibrium.
So the sorts of people
installing and using the app
may be more likely to be able to
find the advanced features,
such as a lock screen widgets.
So I think it's kind
of a tricky call.
But yeah, I think some of the
challenges that we talked
about, the fact that you can't
even give really simple,
step-by-step instructions on
how to install the widget
means that, well, if you're the
one who has to explain how
to install widgets, your chances
of them finding it,
and finding it useful, probably
are pretty low.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I always
used to hate it when somebody
would install an icon for
their live wallpaper.
Right, that--
and the only thing that made
me think otherwise was that
Roman's widget is not
just a widget.
It's also a container
for other widgets.
RETO MEIER: Yes.
Yes, that's a good point.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Something
to think about.
We'd love to hear what you guys
think about that, and
other questions.
So go ahead and give us a
shout-out on Google+.
RETO MEIER: And we'll
be back next week.
Don't forget to join Roman,
Nick, and Adam on Android
Designing Action next Tuesday.
And until the next week,
I'm Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
RETO MEIER: And this has
been in The App Clinic.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Goodbye.